hallo hallo hier ist mal wieder und
wieder gesund und munter daheim
angekommen wir wir wollten uns einfach
mal für die ganzen glückwünsche bedanken
ihr habt ja ziemlich fleißig geschrieben
kommentiert wie in der gepostet bei
facebook und bei youtube war wirklich
eine schöne zeit in hamburg auch eine
anstrengende zeit
aber dadurch dass er so viel
unterstützung erhalten haben von euch
unser viele mutig um halt immer weiter
gemacht und es hat sich gelohnt
ja genau also wir haben jetzt nämlich
über jeden einzelnen kommentar gefreut
darüber die ganzen glückwünsche dass ihr
einfach so viel anteil daran genommen
habe dass wir auch weiterkommen und das
hat uns auch noch sehr weitergeholfen
immer bei unseren entscheidungen auch
welche sagen okay wir gehen einfach mit
einem schuss risiko
schön auch dass manche mit gemeint haben
23 kommentare ich muss von mietwagen da
mussten wir auch ganz arg da ist es
wirklich viel druck und viel last
einfach so vom herzen gefallen
genau uns einfach so ein schönes gefühl
jetzt werde man ging da eigentlich ohne
erwartungen hin und kam jetzt mit dem
besten ergebnis wie daheim
sally auch mit ihren zwei große kriege
leider habe ich gar nicht eingeholt weil
er zeigt das mädchen war perfekt und ich
hab dir alle hassen dass er den rose
täglich gegeben hat das haben wir
überhaupt nicht eilig haben im
nachhinein sagt ender und geben können
plötzlich sehe ich dann bei facebook und
in der mediathek und ich haben rosen ja
perfekt
ja ja ja auf jeden fall gibt es
natürlich die rezepte jetzt auch band
also ich hab jetzt hat die woche noch
frei also frei frei sagt unterricht
vorbereitet aber wird auch gucken dass
ich euch die rezepte einstellen gerade
diese upside down kuchen da gucke ich
dass ich dann ziemlich schnell machen
es stimmt das da hat sie an mich gedacht
die kripo bittet den sechs kinder ziel
und dann heißt bei enthalten
ja ja ja mit dem cello stopps dann kann
sehr gern mal in dem einen oder anderen
video hallo sage ihr mich dabei haben
wollt er bei dem smart gucken das ja
auch zeit hat es gibt noch werde auf
jeden fall mal wieder nach hamburg
fahren
dort startet das freilich nichts von der
stadt gesehen haben ganz zwischen küche
im hotel bewegt studio hotel studio
diesmal mit otto genau also das wird
unser nächster plan zu sagen vielleicht
schauen wir noch mal vorbei vielleicht
dem land noch mal hallo und kommen dann
aber mit genau dass sie genau wie gesagt
wir würden uns einfach mal bedanken
auch für die vielen kommentare für die
bewertung war wirklich alles ganz toll
habe alles gelesen
außer wenn einem ein oder andere
kommentar mal untergegangen ist aber
wirklich wer muss am abend hin zu setzen
haben jeden kommentar gelesen immer
schön gefällt mir kommentiert ja
geantwortet und es war wirklich sehr
schön normale finger ja dann bis ganz
bald